so I've got video today of just really
good work by CBS reporter Paula Reid
yesterday I already told you that at the
White House coronavirus press briefing
Donald Trump played this montage
compilation propaganda video whose
creation in and of itself might have
actually violated campaign finance laws
because it was essentially a campaign
video produced by the administration but
by the administration and played at a
White House press briefing despite the
fact that it's really more of a campaign
ad and in the video the narrative made
the case that at every opportunity at
every instance at every inflection point
Donald Trump did everything perfectly he
did everything as early as he could have
done it he did everything as well and as
efficiently as it could have been done
but the video that he played talks a lot
about what was going on in January
before we had our first case and then it
skips February and talks a lot about the
decisions that Donnell made Trump made
in March
it's like February didn't even happen
which was actually the key month and
that's when Donald Trump should have
been doing stuff but wasn't even the
last ten days of January after our first
case Donald Trump mostly golfed and did
nothing other than downplaying the
threat of the virus so CBS's Paula Reid
good for her confronts Donald Trump and
says your video skips February what the
hell were you doing in February my words
not hers and Trump doesn't like to be
confronted especially not by reporters
especially not by female reporters we
know that and it went about the way you
would expect it to go you didn't use it
to ramp up testing right so it's so
disgraceful the way you said it
let me just listen I just went over it
nobody thought we should do it and what
I did it what do you do when you have no
case in a whole United States when you
excuse me so I want to stop here briefly
this is important the video skips
February why does it skip February what
Trump keeps talking about January 17
January 17 we have no cases we had no
cases what was I going to do our first
case was January 20th this is a
calculated disinformation tactic Trump
picks a day 72 hours before the first
case and says what else was I going to
do at that point then he skips to what
he did in March the whole point is and
Paula Reid's questioning is about the
10-day period after the first case right
January 22 January 31 that's when you
should have been doing things and you
golfed South Korea developed a test
rolled it out widely isolated people
developed fever clinics did contact
tracing South Korea to this day has 222
deaths not per day total that's not a
typo total South Korea has two to two
deaths 1,500 people died in the u.s.
just yesterday alone because during this
key period January 22 31 Trump did
nothing and that's why he keeps talking
about January 17 let's continue you
reported it zero cases zero deaths On
January 17 January 30 and in fact we'll
give you a list what we did in fact part
of it was up there we did a lot so here
Trump having to fall back on will give
you a list of what we did which some
flunky can come up with later which will
of course be mostly bogus and it was in
the video well it wasn't in the video
that's the whole point of what Paula
Reid is asking about the February the
entire month of February is missing from
the video that you played let's look at
just a little more of this and Trump
becomes furious with Paula Reid she's
doing a good job he attacks her his fake
he says most of the reporters in the
room are also fake you know you're a
fake you know that your whole network
the way you cover it is fake and most of
it and not all of you but the people are
wise to you that's why you have a lower
lower proved already than you've ever
had before times probably three and when
you ask me that
let me ask you this why did inviting why
didn't why did Biden apologize why did
he write a letter of apology karo that's
very important in Nepal why did the
Democrats think that I acted too quickly
you know why because they really thought
that I acted too quickly nothing uh
nothing screams confidence like
attacking the reporter and talking about
Joe Biden right so we are in an
authoritarian nightmare the attacks on
the press won't stop and meanwhile Trump
continues to mismanage every element of
this we have to get him out that's why
I'm with Bernie who says we've got to
vote for Biden that's why I'm with Noam
Chomsky who says we must remove Trump
and Biden won't be exciting but he will
clearly be much better than Trump we
have to do it this has to stop we'll
have more about this on our Instagram
page at David Pakman show and remember
follow my 20/20 bourbon gardening
experience by following me on instagram
at david pakman I've got my raised beds
built I've got dirt showing up soon I
guess it's called soil maybe dirt dirt
calling it dirt suggests I'm clueless
which is right but in any case follow
the adventure at David Pakman one of our
sponsors is cuts clothing giving you 15%
off their entire collection of super
quality men's t-shirts at david
pakman.com slash cuts that's cu TS the
solid color t-shirt is a core component
of any guy's wardrobe certainly of mine
which is all the more reason why you
should love the t-shirts in your closet
it impacts your day-to-day life your
typical poorly made t-shirt scratches it
shrinks the neck stretches the color
fades the whole thing warps over time
none of those things happen with cuts
clothing as soon as I put one of their
shirts on for the first time I noticed
the comfort I notice the quality I
notice the look and the fit and it's
actually it's a noticeable level of
quality which would be appropriate for
something like going on a date or going
into the office if you're watching on
you
I am wearing the classic Henley right
now as you can see go check out what
cuts clothing has to offer you will see
and feel the difference as soon as you
put it on the slogan is it's the only
shirt worth wearing and you will see why
and you'll get 15% off what's better
than that by going to david pakman.com
slash cuts that's david pakman.com slash
c UTS